I wasn't really planning to do a segment about
this, but there have been so many bad takes
coming from [inaudible] I guess
what we're calling the revolutionary left.
That's the non pejorative term that we've,
I guess agreed on, uh, to describe them about
the resignation of Bolivian president Evo
Morales that I feel compelled to discuss it
because the right is just completely uninformed
about Latin American politics.
So I really don't have any message for them,
but there are a lot of people on the left
that are either misunderstanding or just wrong
in their conclusions about what has taken
place in Bolivia over the last, uh, close
to 15 years, calling it in completely black
and white terms, a military coup.
So my goal here is to go through the whole
story.
Hopefully this will be enlightening.
I know I'll be called a shill and all of this
stuff, but who cares, right?
I mean, we, we, uh, we get one shot at doing
things the way we actually see them.
You only live once.
And I'm going to do the stories with the nuance
that I think they deserve because that's really
what's missing.
The problem is there is too much black and
white thinking in general in politics, people
are either good or bad.
The military is either good or bad.
Socialism is either good or bad.
A politician is either a savior or a villain,
and I know lots of people who work in the
field of mental health and they tell me, you
know, a lot of the people that come in that
I see they have in their lives, all sorts
of different things going on that at their
root are often caused by black and white thinking
about gray areas in life, about jobs, about
relationships, about their childhood, whatever.
And I believe that the same is happening in
politics and specifically with the Bolivia
situation.
So let's try to put that aside.
Let's just all talk like reasonable people.
No one's shilling here.
Some people may be missing some of the facts.
Some people may be coming to conclusions that
are tanged by ideology.
Let's not make these umbrella black and white
declarations and let's try to actually figure
out what's going on.
So the Bolivian president, Evo Morales, was
first in office in 2006 a few days ago.
He resigned at the request or demand of the
Bolivian military and request or demand we
can argue about.
But it's not actually the most important thing.
Why did this happen a few days ago?
There has been rampant speculation about the
most recent election of being a bogus election.
The organization of American States put out
a report saying that the election results
were manipulated, including alterations, forced
signatures, and wide-scale data manipulation.
Uh, now there is already a debate about this.
Well, does that mean the election was bogus
or are these just reports of irregularities
like you have in many elections, including
here in the United States.
But for me, the real story is actually bigger
than this.
And I want to ask you this hypothetical.
If Donald Trump during his second term, imagine
he gets reelected in November and he gets
a second term.
Imagine that during that second term Donald
Trump change the constitution to allow a third
term effective immediately, but then also
claimed that since the constitution was changed,
his second term is sort of really his first
term under the new constitution, so he should
actually get two more.
And then during the third term, which is really
his fourth, he loses a referendum to allow
unlimited terms and then his Supreme court
justices that he has selected, say, forget
about the term limits.
You can stay as long as you want.
Wouldn't we in that situation as Progressive's
who are for the rule of law, wouldn't we be
begging someone to force Donald Trump out?
Okay.
Now let's talk about what happened in Bolivia.
Evo Morales was elected in 2006 and people
were excited because there were good things
about his election.
He is not, it's not black and white.
He was the first ethnically indigenous president
of Bolivia.
That's great.
In a country that has such a large indigenous
population.
Why did it take so long to have an indigenous
president? Fantastic, lovely.
He reduced poverty during his first term.
He offered a much more sensible and pragmatic
version of the socialism that has been espoused
by Hugo Chavez and Nicolas Maduro.
He invested in infrastructure and development
and grew the middle-class great, but like
with many of these Latin American socialists
of the last many decades, he's a an increasingly
authoritarian.
There's corruption.
He was elected to a five year term in 2006
he got a new constitution adopted while he
was president, which allowed two terms.
Then in 2009 he called for early elections
one and said, Hey, this is sort of really
like my first term because I didn't complete
the first term.
Under the old constitution, we have a new
constitution, so I should really be able to
run again in 2014 it's not objective, really
bad to change a constitution, but one should
not be allowed to stay in office longer than
they were originally supposed to because of
changes made under their watch.
That's what authoritarians do, so this is
already bad.
He wins that early 2009 election calls it
his first term.
So now he's allowed to run again in 2014 and
a court increasingly under his control says,
yes, he is allowed to run again.
This will count as his second term, not as
his third or his first term, not as a second.
He wins in 2014 and then says, well, let's
do a referendum to abolish term limits altogether
so that I can just continue being reelected
and reelected indefinitely.
Voters reject that referendum in Bolivia.
So what does he do?
He appeals once again to a constitutional
court filled with people, loyal to him who
say, yep, you know what?
Running for office is a human right.
And Bolivia term limits violate the human
rights of everyone Monarrez so he can run
again, which he does and wins in adult and
an election determined to have significant
irregularities, some characterizing it as
completely bogus.
So listen, do I want the military to take
control of the country now?
Hell no.
I'm from Argentina.
I know what happens when the military takes
control.
It's bad.
Is this a black, white military coup?
No, that's an extraordinarily myopic interpretation
that completely ignores history in Bolivia
for the last 13 years, if an American president
did 25% of what [inaudible] did in the election
system in Bolivia, we'd all be demanding their
removal.
You'll hear comments like, well, this all
happened because American banking and finance
has ruined these countries, including Bolivia.
How does that force the president to change
the constitution to remain in power longer
and how does it excuse it?
These things are not as cut and dry as the
revolutionary left is making them out to be.
So my request to you is don't fall for the
black and white thinking and of course the
revolutionary left will say anyone who is
not loudly opposed to this is a pro military
coup, pro-American interventionists, Yankee
shill.
Let's be adults.
Guys, give me a break.
The world is not black and white the way you
make it out.
Everyone.
I listed some good things early in his presidency.
He also is corrupt.
We are also seeing a lot of the same things
happened in Bolivia that we've seen happen
in other places in Latin America like Venezuela
and others.
When these authoritarian leaning socialists,
um, uh, remain in power for longer and longer
periods of time.
Now interestingly, the left and right share
the existence of these factions who suffer
from black and white thinking on the right,
you have these libertarians and small government
people who think they're black and white principals
tell them everything they need to know.
On the left you've got the revolutionary left
who suffers from, you know, a version of the
same affliction where they see a situation
and they say, Oh yeah, the military is involved
and it's bad and a socialist is the president
and that's good.
And he's an ethnic minority.
So that's, that's it.
That's the analysis and anything else that's
completely unacceptable.
You're pushed out if you don't fall in line
with that ideology.
Tell me all the ways I'm wrong on the facts.
A, I'm ready for it, but let's not play these
just completely toxic black and white games
that unfortunately are happening among a contingent
of the left.